seguirá al mando de Grecia el líder
conservador del partido Nueva democracia
obtuvo la victoria que deseaba en las
elecciones legislativas de este domingo
y Alaba con el resultado electoral de
hoy Grecia abre un nuevo capítulo
histórico en su camino por segunda vez
en pocas semanas los ciudadanos no solo
nos envían un mensaje de continuidad en
el camino que emprendimos hace 4 años
sino que nos han dado un mandato firme
para avanzar más deprisa por la senda de
los grandes cambios que necesita nuestro
país
el Primer Ministro se llevó más del 40%
de los votos una contundente diferencia
frente a su rival de izquierda Alexis
reconoció la
derrotabilidades que le fueron
entregadas hoy por el voto popular con
procesos coordinados y colectivos como
corresponde a un partido democrático y
participativo adelantaremos los procesos
para tomar nuestras decisiones finales
se trató de la segunda selecciones
legislativas en Grecia esta vez no
democracia obtuvo una mayoría absoluta
lo que le daría al menos 158 escaños de
los 300 del parlamento Heleno sus
partidarios celebraron los resultados
estoy muy contenta obviamente
esperábamos estos resultados lo hará aún
mejor nuestro Primer Ministro ya ha
hecho un trabajo excelente
dositos marcaron la carrera electoral la
colisión entre dos trenes que dejó 57
muertos y que puso en la mira la
infraestructura del país y el naufragio
de una embarcación en las costas griegas
con 750 personas según indicaron los
sobrevivientes a pesar de ello los
griegos optaron por la continuidad de
mitsutakis que promete grandes reformas
y seguir con la recuperación económica
del país